if you roll a 6-sided die and a
four-sided die what is the probability
that neither die shows a one the grid
below shows all the possible outcomes of
rolling a six-sided die and a four-sided
die
and we're fairly familiar with six-sided
die those are the cubes that were used
to from the board games that we've been
playing our entire lives that look
something like that and your roll is
whatever is the face-up
you're probably less familiar with
four-sided die these are more of like
these these triangular pyramids they
look something like this so it has one
two three and then the one side on the
bottom and here your roll is actually
the face the side that is facing the
bottom and so what you have here is a
picture of all the possible rolls they
have the six-sided die the side that's
facing on the top and then on the
triangle this shows what what what is
the result of the roll of the four-sided
die so this actually would be the side
that's facing down let's actually try to
answer their question because they gave
us all of the possible outcomes of
rolling a six-sided die and a four-sided
die so we want to know what is the
probability that neither die shows a 1
so how many total outcomes do we have
let's see 1 2 3 4 by 1 2 3 4 5 6 4 times
6 that makes sense there's six possible
outcomes for the six-sided die four
possible outcomes for the four-sided die
4 times 6 so there's 24 total possible
outcomes and then how many of the
outcomes meet our constraint that
neither die shows a 1 so this one so
anything in this row isn't going to meet
our constraint because these have these
have a one on the four-sided die and
nothing in this column is going to meet
our constraint because these have a one
on the six-sided die but all of these
everything left over are going to make
these are going to meet our constraints
these are going to meet our constraints
and how many of these outcomes are there
well see there's 3 by 4 3 times 4 so
there's 12 12 possible outcomes here 12
over 24 is the probability you could say
there's a 12 24 it's probability but if
you wanted to write it as an equivalent
fraction that has using lower numbers
this is the same thing as
divide the numerator and denominator by
12 as 1/2 as 1/2 so the probability that
we that that neither die shows a 1 is
1/2